e l'oscar per la discussione più inutile
degli ultimi anni va twitter italia per
la sua capacità di rendere un evento
apparentemente interessante con una
merda quindi l'italia è stata premiata
per questo perché dovete capire che è
molto difficile essere dei critici
cinematografici in 140 caratteri
ma a quanto pare loro ce la fanno
comunque sto parlando appunto degli
oscar 2014 innanzitutto vi chiedo scusa
per l'ennesima volta se l'audio è
cambiato ma la casa nuova e così ha più
o meno la stessa insonorizzazione della
bat caverna e anche lo stesso numero di
insetti circa ma parliamo di questi
oscar la premiazione più importante
dell'anno fondo dal paesi piu
patriottico del mondo ogni anno si
radunano i giurati si masturbano davanti
film che parlano della storia americana
oh mio dio ovvio di 12 anni schiavo o
mio di uno frustano oh oh oh mio dio
dito o ha vinto ma c'è da dire che era
comunque il film ormai questa
premiazione la prendo come l'ex tasto mi
sento fortunato di google
l'accordo giusto per scoprire film che
da noi non sono neanche arrivate e
quindi buon vecchio matthew maguire ruba
la statuetta di caprio o così sembra no
perché chi capi ormai lo sappiamo estro
mosè di diventato bravissimo dico è
diventato perché io me lo ricordo quando
ero uscito titanic dove non c'è la mezza
persona che avesse membri centale
mastini che riuscisse a dire wow che
bravo attore
nessuno ma dobbiamo dargli credito nel
corso degli anni è diventato un mostro
spero solo non faccia la fine di johnny
depp che se non gli dai un cappello un
buffo lui non esiste ma non sempre
il caso spero per tutti i giorni del
nuovo è stato un furto siete dei ladri
non dovevate dare a lui non ci sono
prima le mezze stagioni e sinceramente
non so quanto avrei dato a di caprio
l'oscar per questo film cioè sia dovuto
pippare con l'hd ad alcuno di una
modella ma se gli hanno gridato no
quello che credo io e se fosse lui mi
piacerebbe riceverlo per un film un po
più impegnato nonché mondolfo balls
tifoso brutto film per amor di dio ma
per esempio l'ho preferito molto di più
in shutter island o revolutionary road
che probabilmente abbiamo visto solo io
e sua zia ma non è solo questo vuole
fare una domanda non ti hanno visto il
film di matthew mag lo quanti l'hanno
veramente visto per poter dire che di
caprio meritasse l'oscar e che non lo
stanno dicendo soltanto perché è di
caprio quanti susa ha infatti ho tutti
gli altri film in gara che non si è
cagato nessuno per poter dare
un'opinione
e poi vorrei porre un altra questione la
questione della recitazione appunto come
vuoi tu italiano seduto con il culo
sulla sedia giudicare la recitazione di
un attore americano
se guardi il film doppiato e questo è la
solita discussione della piaggio fa
cagare oa l'adattamento affumicato tutte
le battute non è proprio anche se di
come puoi giudicare un boom una prova
attoriale se la voce chi stai sentendo
non è la sua
io credo che non si possa perché la
recitazione meno negli ultimi 100 anni
non si basa più solo sul viso e sul
corpo per esprimere qualcosa ma
moltissimo dalla voce appunto
dall'intonazione con cui si dicono le
cose
da quanto si credibile e come puoi dire
se un attore e credibile o no se la sua
performance è incredibile no se stai
sentendo la voce del doppiatore
dell'attore io potrei farvi vedere
qualsiasi scena di the wolf of wall
street e con il sottofondo pv e come se
io pongo parlasse a voi non ci fosse la
mia voce
ma si può essere quella di un'altra
persona gravity invece si mangia tutti
gli altri oscar
io mi immagino quaroni che ho letto una
sua intervista dove diceva non farò mai
più un fiume come gravity è stata una
cosa difficilissima io gli credo
per me lo immagino con tutti gli oscar
il braccio che li accarezza tipo possa
artiglio del rispetto regate ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo
vicenza devo dire che carica il mio film
preferito del 2013 non solo per le
immagini potentissime che linea sbattuto
in faccia più volte ma ma anche perché
io sono un patito delle storie dove che
parlano di isolamento
magari anche nello spazio del classico
mistero dell'universo l'isolamento che
ho provato guardando sandra bullock
perse in mare di stelle e raramente sono
riuscito a trovarlo al cinema è un anno
un punto di forza del film che c'erano
pochissimi dialoghi e con attori come
santa culu che george clooney è una
mamma una povera sandra bullock e che ha
fatto dei film recenti ha fatto un film
decente e george clooney lo ricordiamo
tutti per aver quasi affondato la saga
di batman facendo bruce weber
quindi grazie e sceneggiatore di gravity
e dulcis in fundo il motivo per cui
siamo qui ballare in questo dannatissimo
film nebraska nara parliamo della grande
bellezza la grande bellezza è un film
già come appunto ha scritto di viaggio
su twitter la grande bellezza non è
nient'altro che un film è questo ho
scritto non solo per ricordarlo a chi se
n'è dimenticato ma soprattutto l'aspetto
per twitter che ci ha fatto due palle
così la parola destra che ci diceva che
era bello la palla a sinistra che ci
diceva che non lo era è tutto come detto
prima fu 140 caratteri
adesso tu mi devi dire come cazzo fai a
descrivere un film che ha vinto un oscar
con 140 caratteri più o meno
e questo poi ti è piaciuto e grande
bellezza se moltissimo è molto bello ha
detto a me non tanto basta che non
capisce un cazzo
dov'è finita la sana discussione anche i
tempi e si ho 25 anni e sto dicendo anni
i tempi quando si ama vedere un film che
ci piace se non ci piacesse nasce una
discussione e queste discussioni
duravano per giorni per mesi per anni e
si andava ad analizzarmi primo nel naso
di ogni singolo protagonista ora ora
quando si discute di un film non è più
sul perché ti è piaciuto perché non ti è
piaciuto ma sul io ho ragione tu no che
quello si può riassumere in un cazzo
grosso ed uno alla fine sempre quello
cento il removibile che diciamo questo
film ha vinto l'oscar e c'è invece un po
più alternativa che mastica di web che
diceva apre la grande bellezza a quanto
stiamo mi piace non mi piace a sono più
mi piace a me non piace la grande
bellezza ma nessuno diceva il perché è
quello che interessa di meter che ci è
piaciuto dimmi perché tu non ti è
piaciuto timi perché probabilmente tutti
avevano un perché
ma stavano discutendo su twitter che è
nato soltanto per scrivere quando sei in
bagno sto pagando hashtag caccia questo
caso di cieli della roma talmente banale
da dire ma che se sto dicendo è perché è
successa veramente per quanto riguarda
me invece la mia opinione sulla grande
bellezza e che vi devo dire
siete sicuri che volete un'opinione da
ugo che considera michael bay uno che fa
kim divertenti o che si è riuscito a
sparare tutta la filmografia di steven
seagal divertendosi o che riesce ad
accettare opinioni diverse dalla sua
una delle argomentazioni bandi dietro o
magari che prende soltanto il cinema per
quello che è pura e semplice empatia è
un po come sia uno a cui non piace la
lasagna entra in un ristorante va dal
primo seduto sul tavolo vicino a lui che
sta mangiando lasagna un'area e faccia
di merda non capisce un cazzo questa fa
schifo sei semplicemente la
rappresentazione di quello che dici lo
stronzo